pour les téléspectateurs je vous le dis
tout de suite je risque de perdre une
dent une dent provisoire à tout moment
d'ailleurs je crois que je suis en train
de la perdre mais je vous jure que c'est
vrai voilà donc je la mets là non mais
je vous jure
côté beauté vous avez vu dans provisoire
que je dois faire refaire là à demain en
fait j'ai mangé du chocolat avant
d'arriver et j'ai senti un moment une
noisette qui était plus dure que les
autres et en fait c'était un bouton donc
voilà j'ai rendez vous demain à 13h 15
chez le dentiste comme ça je vous dis
tout haut eh ben voilà donc voilà la
dent et la voilà merci ions robot voilà
si on peut montrer la dent donc voilà
j'ai 39 ans mais pas toutes mes dents
voilà comme ça vous le savez mais ça va
j'ai toujours l'habitude de perdre et
j'espère capture mais la patience et
[Musique]